make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are picking up with the
official event of Joker war and I love
this story like this is amazing here's
the other thing too it's good to see
Jorge here's the thing I'm not sure
exactly how it's pronounced is it Jorge
Jimenez or is it Jorge
Jimenez I'm not sure how to pronounce it
because I know that the J is silent in
Spanish but I think it's only sung on
under certain circumstances so I'm not
sure but nonetheless we are picking up
with with the very beginning of Joker
award and this is a cool thing because
what this does is it actually picks up
years ago right at some point presumably
in the early days of Batman's career
there's a couple reasons why we can kind
of put this together and I'll talk about
that here in a second but what's
happened here is the various experiences
of Batman in dealing with the Joker are
starting to come to a head in the sense
that all these individuals who are
killed to the Joker toxin are deformed
in some pretty gruesome ways now the
crazy thing about this is you don't
really see people like that in recent in
recent days right in recent years with
the use of Joker toxin right they just
kind of seem to die with a smile on
their face but what these really
gruesome expressions and gruesome
appearances it's messed up but it's kind
of cool to see at the same time right to
kind of show the heinous Ness and the
callousness of the Joker reflected in
how people look when they perish at the
hand of the Joker toxin it's kind of
wild but one of the things that's going
on here of course Alfred being alive but
Batman talking to him and Alfred kind of
asked the question how many has this
quote-unquote Joker figure already
killed and Batman kind of responds by
I'm not really sure this is going to end
in that kind of a thing so the
discussion they're having is that they
don't really fully understand who this
joker guy is or what he's about and this
all really point to the idea that
they've just encountered the Joker
seemingly for the very first time or in
the very early days now the reason why
this matters is because we go back to
Batman zero you and we go back to the
origin of the Joker at least some
insofar as we got during the new 52 then
we have this idea of when Batman first
encountered Joker that happened in the
very very early days of him becoming a
superhero right so we're talking about
within like the first two to three years
of Bruce Wayne becoming Batman when when
this took place this is very very early
on but one of the things that Bruce
Wayne picks up on pretty easily is that
the Joker's motivations as he said in
Batman the Animated Series his schemes
make sense to no one but himself and
that's what makes the Joker so dangerous
one of the things that Batman kind of
picks up on here is that when it comes
to the average criminal they do what
they do because of money or be
the thrill right whatever the case is
like they do it as a contract killing
right so it's like when Agnes Heller
outlined the three reasons why people
commit crimes right people commit crimes
for profit in which case the
consequences don't matter people commit
crimes out of passion right like some
guy or some girl comes home and finds
her significant other cheating on they
lose their minds and stab to death or
they do it out of compulsion they
couldn't help themselves but regardless
of the situation neither of these three
things mattered to the consequences the
third one seems to be what what applies
to the Joker there for whatever reason
he sees the whole world is basically
meat in the eyes of the Joker
everybody's already dead all he's doing
is just kind of helping them along the
way and achieving his own goal in the
process but it's this really almost
wholesome moment right when he's talking
to Alfred and Alfred like there's no way
I'd let you face off against a guy like
this on your own for the rest of your
life right and so what this does is it
allows basically Batman to kind of break
or at least you know the bat won't be
able to break into an aqueduct for all
that kind of stuff to go nuts right
Bruce Wayne driving his Batmobile but
more so than that we get these sort of
news flips right Wayne Enterprises is
experiencing what's basically a hostile
takeover in the sense that Joker has
taken over all the assets of Wayne
Enterprises right that Bruce Wayne
himself has basically indicated a kind
of pattern of embezzlement siphoning
money off of Wayne Enterprises illegally
and then using it for personal means
that Harlan graves you guys know him as
the under broker from the last few
stories that we did he's the guy who's
basically the legal counsel for Wayne
Enterprises now and the other part of
this is that the the Gotham Gazette
received a multibillion-dollar cease and
desist right so they were basically told
if you don't stop publishing these
articles saying the Joker's the one who
took over Wayne Enterprises we're gonna
sue you guys into oblivion which of
course the news ended up giving away
because you know 2020 that's what the
news does but nonetheless is what are
these things were that were basically
from all different directions Wayne
Enterprises in its entirety is now
completely and totally under control of
the Joker and his henchmen right Batman
is it not only busy does he not have any
control of this company he's wanted for
embezzlement and so this guy's back is
against the wall in almost every
conceivable way the other part of this
is that when it comes to Lucius Fox he's
basically and he's basically infected
with the Joker toxin not in the most
extreme degree but just enough to where
that punchline can get the kind of
information that she needs out of him so
she can relay it to the Joker and what
she wants to know are all the different
locations that Batman
within the city of Gotham but more
specifically within Wayne Enterprises
that he can use in any particular point
in time now again this is a great way
for James Tinian to actually feed off of
what we've seen over the years from
Scott Snyder's new 52 run this is one of
the things that Snyder brought in we're
in the various buildings that were built
by Wayne Enterprises or purchased by
Wayne Enterprises the Batman had put in
these little you know kind of mini bat
caves that he could operate out of in
almost any situation right so no matter
what the emergency is he can go there
and he can operate out of that place and
so where Lucius Fox kind of asked the
question where's the Joker gone to
punchline says where would you go if you
suddenly became worth 100 billion
dollars and so we pick up with the
monarch theatre now the monarch theatre
for those of you guys who don't know is
a significant place in the history of
the Batman mythos and the reason why is
because this is the theatre that Bruce
Wayne and his parents were at when they
left and they were shot to death in
Crime Alley and so you end up having the
owner of the theater who's just kind of
taking the the Joker on a tour through
this place right kind of showy joker
around and he's almost kind of
explaining to the Joker what's going on
right this place used to be part of what
was called Crime Alley this is where the
Wayne's were killed but you couldn't
really walk up and down this street
without having to worry about you know
being being shot or something like that
which really sort of sort of begs the
question why in the world of the way to
family go to the seediest part of town
to see a movie theater right was like
not a theater close to them right they
could have gone to because let me tell
you something guys in in every town
there's two theaters right the theater
is that rich people go to and the movie
theaters rich people used to go to those
are the two kinds of theaters that exist
remember that was an old Chris Rock
routine from back in the day but it's
true right the rich kind of have a
tendency to cut themselves off from
anybody who's deemed to be not rich so I
guess maybe it does say something about
the Wayne family that they spend time at
at the monarch theater but regardless
it's an explanation here by this guy and
in basically saying this place has a has
a pretty rough history about it right
like there's almost a kind of spirit of
vengeance almost kind of spirit of
haunting that that permeates throughout
this place whereas just sadness and
misery all this time because following
the death of the Wayne's and and really
kind of the collapse of this part of
Gotham nobody really goes there anymore
and it's kind of a crazy theme because
even Wayne you know Bruce Wayne is
showing up here a couple times and tried
to buy this place and was always turned
down every single time and so where this
you know owner basically says he kind of
hears what sounds like laughter the
response of the Joker is well it's
probably just the wind right you know
old theaters like this they probably
that kind of wind going through here and
so what we end up learning is that the
Joker approach this owner with a massive
amount of money now we're not given an
actual numerical value but we can kind
of specify that it's enough to buy a
small town right you know so it was it's
probably in the millions if not possibly
in the the double-digit Millions it's an
exceedingly high amount of money and so
what is up happening is this guy
continually kind of picks up on the fact
there's some kind of laughter here and
the Joker says you know what you should
go join them in the audience this shows
getting ready to start and this guy
doesn't know where the Joker is talking
about of course the Joker's watching the
Mark of Zorro which is the movie that
Bruce Wayne and his family were watching
when they left the theater and they were
killed but basically we end up finding
out that all these individuals out there
who are Joker eyes are sitting down in
the audience and of course this uh sure
this movie owner is gonna go the same
way right he's gonna get Joker eyes too
and that's basically gonna be the end of
him but again it's kind of nuts because
if you have this scenario where Bruce
Wayne finally makes his way into the
Wayne Enterprises building and when that
happens he kind of just starts looking
around right analyzing where the various
people are all the hinton with guns and
it's the smartest move of the Joker to
put in as many people here as possible
right to station everybody on every
conceivable floor not only that because
Batman basically gains access directly
into one of the mini bat caves one of
the micro caves he almost kind of
assumes is a safe haven but as soon as
the lights come on you've got trench
line there who immediately goes after
him now here's the important thing to
understand punchline has no chance
against Batman right so before people
start comedy no away punchline would win
yeah we know like we know punchline
wouldn't win against Batman right at
that point you're just preaching to the
audience you're just stating the obvious
right like the sky is blue that's all it
really comes down to but it's kind of a
funny thing and this is what I love
about how James Tinian handles this
because you've got punchline on one side
you've got Bruce Wayne on the other
under any normal circumstances when I
say normal I mean
punchline being herself and the only way
she could win and she had the powers of
Superman she still comes out on top and
the reason why is because you have this
moment where she goes in attacks Bruce
and Bruce basically kind of implements
these small little things here and there
these small little devices the punchline
knows about all these right the booby
traps and things that are there this
kind of iconic Batman suit that's there
right like this holy new Batman suit
that I've never seen before but looks
amazing it looks so cool it's almost
kind of like a John Henry iron steal
Batman's
you know like like Superman sweet but
for Batman there's almost kind of what
it looks like right like okay here's
what I want to know everybody watching
this video if you could name this Batman
suit what would you name it you know so
we're gonna call this video the new
Batman suit like if you could name this
suit what would you call it that's what
I want to know cuz it looks cool and by
the other thing and this is why this is
why I love the way Tinian handles this
is it again like it's punch line in the
room Batman in the room punch line is
gonna lose but then we end up finding
out that what she's been doing here is
Batman starts to kind of get a little
hazy where I get a little foggy in the
brain a little sluggish and punch line
basically tells them oh what's actually
going on here is that I have I've been
permeating this room with poisonous
entire time it's one part Joker toxin
it's one point fear toxin and one point
venom and the venom you know the venom
basically prevents the Joker toxin from
killing you but it basically enhances
what goes on with the fear toxin right
so we're kind of like this wicked
cocktail and this is genius
man but it's so cool because the initial
knee-jerk reaction of this would be like
no way Batman would go into this but his
you're the thing out today you have to
understand Batman wouldn't expect
anybody to know that he has these little
micro caves they're probably not even on
the blueprints right the only person who
would know about it
is Lucius Fox and the expectation is
that Lucius Fox isn't hiding Nuala would
really be able to get to him in the
conventional way and so it's cool right
because it's just a way to kind of get
the upper hand on Batman the thing is
like once he starts making his way or at
least he tries to leave suddenly he's
met by the voice of Alfred saying like
hey you're going the wrong way you're
going backwards and when Batman it's
kinda like Alfred what in the heck is
going on then like Alfred chimes in and
says like he's taking everything white
he's taking the vehicles he's taking
your city he's taking everything you
have to get out of there and Batman
looks up and realizes the batwing is
flying towards him right this Joker eyes
batwing is flying towards him and it
says and Batman's like one of them were
like you're supposed to be dead right
and alphas responses I'm sorry my boy
I'm so sorry
we're all dead now and that happens
right is this thing open fires directly
on Bruce Wayne right so like the batwing
looks like it kills Batman oh that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here two
comments explain make sure you guys are
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later purse
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]